hey guys what's happening it's coming
for a ball game run they're coming for
you Logan run ah yesterday Logan Paul
uploaded a video titled
we found a dead body into the suicide
forest with this very tasteful thumbnail
this must be a great video can't wait a
click on this he didn't actually show a
dead body in his video no I know he's
out for that daily grind for views but
surely even Logan Paul has his limits
now I always knew that Logan Paul was a
jackass so I wasn't really surprised by
the fact that once Logan Paul found a
dead body that he acted like a jackass
it didn't really come as a shock to me
but for those who don't know that what
happened basically he found a dead body
he went up to the body filmed filmed it
literally up close and sort of a sudden
thing you see on this off-brand wet web
site is it's not the kind of stuff you'd
see on YouTube
very disturbing really disrespectful
zooming on the body making weird jokes
around it and people always point out
that Oh Logan he's like the nice one of
the Paul brothers he's dead he's dead
more mature blend no he's not I've been
telling this for years Jay Galle seems
like it's somewhat self-aware but Logan
he's a straight-up sociopath you know
when you're doing that those daily blog
videos there's always what's the next
big thing you know just dangling in
front of you like what's gonna draw more
people to the channel me filming a dead
body
ah not even hesitating I'm not
monetizing this video for obvious
reasons I will say before you watch this
is grass
I think this definitely marks a moment
in youtube history because I'm pretty
sure this has never hopefully happened
to anyone on YouTube ever they try and
sort of mask the whole thing with that
sad music this is graphic I like how he
points out this is a mark for YouTube
history like everything has to be an
achievement to this man cuz I'm pretty
sure this has never hopefully happened
to anyone on YouTube ever I did
something that marks the history of
YouTube I'm amazed he thought this was
appropriate for you so they go to the
well-known forest suicide forest which
is outside Mount Fuji in Japan Japan has
a huge problem with suicide it says but
it's known that you enter the forest to
commit suicide in Japan that's why it
literally has the name suicide for us
also known as the Japanese suicide
forest you know what's gonna happen you
don't have to add that sound effect like
Oh
okey like it's so dumb I can't hey your
ghost in this forest please please leave
us alone
foreshadowing everybody knew this is
gonna happen who what if I entering the
suicide forest going off trail we would
find a dead body never my intention nope
umm I really hate to say this I think
you're sort of hanging right there so
here they found the dead body and hey
thanks filled me
hey all right fill me so I can have this
reaction um I really hate to say this I
think you're sort of hanging right there
mmm I'm not even kidding
you see I'm not even this is no joke
guys that's a [__] person do I shot I
told you I think you're right
god no do what the hammer let's go then
you just say bring the camera let's go
do what the hammer let's go their body
their camera let's go everybody let's go
have a little closer look over there
let's not call the cops let's just bring
the camera make sure you bring the
camera do what the hammer let's go thing
is I don't want to show the video it's
so stupid
I'll just describe it because I don't
want to show it but he basically zooms
in on the corpse he shows the hands he's
right next to it he film said it's just
it's so distasteful it's so
disrespectful and it's so stupid he's
going on I don't know dude why it's
sinking in bro it wasn't supposed to
happen man oh my god stop [__]
showing it what's wrong with you there's
no going back
I've seen things I can't unsee
restricted area
you can't enter it always a little too
late bro I've seen a little too much
[__] you know it was restricted to go
off trail like come on dude there's kids
running around
what if it's stumbled upon this guy oh
there's kids just like all the kids
watching your vlogs Logan wish you
showed anyway what are you saying
that's your audience right there now the
video got on trending people people were
very upset different celebrities Aaron
Paul tweeted philip defranco pointed out
that there was six hundred thousand
likes on the video before it was taken
down his core audience doesn't give up
unless YouTube does something this
doesn't hurt him it's true it's true
yeah I was surprised when I saw the
video and not many people seem to give a
[__]
not until Twitter this morning I'm like
oh yeah people are actually pissed off
about this good because it's so stupid I
mean it literally says in YouTube's
policy that you can't include disturbing
or disgusting video footage I think this
classifies I do think so and seeing it
then appear on trending and it makes you
go like what the weather what is
happening what is what is this can you
imagine the thought process that went
into this like oh yeah so let me just
make this face
and then we'll add him here right well I
make sure you can see him properly and
take off your stupid [__] hat here's
what you do if you find a dead body in a
vlog you either don't don't film the
body at all or at least cut it out of
the vlog because it's inappropriate and
disrespectful to show even if you blur
it or you just cut cut it there you can
talk about it afterwards if you want to
bring attention to it that's completely
fine I think it's important issue to
talk about and they should we shouldn't
shy away from it but just cut it you
don't have to show it and we definitely
don't need to see you zooming in and
walking him on the face of the person
it's disgusting
the thing is I sort of understand the
mentality this would make a great vlog
Logan has made 440 vlogs he does it
every single day and there's always
what's the next big blog what's gonna be
the next big thing that draws people in
of course it's something like this
happens he's gonna want to capitalize on
it he's gonna want to try and draw
attention to him and he knows it's gonna
get more attention if he films the body
shows it in the thumbnail all these
things that he did now a lot of people
in his defense said well he demonetised
the video he added disclaimers well he
even point out himself that there's no
way the video is gonna get monetized
anyway I'm sorry for swearing so much
I'm already getting flack for T - a
vacation bro oh so it's not really a
noble thing to not monetize the video if
you know it's not gonna monetize anyway
a lot of people were pissed off at Logan
for laughing or ridiculing the situation
I don't really have a problem with that
personally I think a lot of people deal
with this sort of thing in their own way
it's obviously a traumatic thing for
anyone to find a dead body for me the
problem is showing it showing the body
filming the body acting like a jackass
still in front of them there's no way
you needed to show that you could have
reviewed it afterwards in the Edit and
said hey let's cut this out since then
Logan has issued an apology which is the
first apology I've ever seen that has an
emoji sign in it and the hashtag he also
mentioned himself 26 times in this
apology he points out that he didn't do
it for the views because he already gets
views yeah [__] right dude shut the
[__] up you might be fooling your kid
audience but you ain't fooling me
alright you 100% did it for the views
you put a dead man in your thumbnail
explain that I'm surrounded by good
people do what the hammer let's go visit
there's a thing that is now in our lives
I think what this video really does is
it encompasses everything wrong with
YouTube that clickbait the
sensationalism the thing that's got to
keep pushing at the end of the day he
just shines bad on everyone now I'm by
no means a good example of talking about
this but no one is perfect we
we all make mistakes I I think
yeah I know but this one I have a few
experiences with this sort of thing but
actions speak louder than words
in my opinion which seems to be
overlooked every time for me at least I
never did anything towards another human
being I just said things that you
weren't supposed to say and to me it's
it's a big big difference in my opinion
he did apologize you know no matter how
bad the apology is he did apologize
people are outraged and they want some
sort of like oh here's the channel
should be taken down or this or that and
obviously I don't believe in that no
matter what like I don't believe in that
lose your job kind of hate mob he should
that some bigger sort of consequence
should come out of this but he
definitely deserved to be criticized at
the very least suicide is a serious
issue and shouldn't take be taking light
then lightly can't speak I'm gonna leave
some link in the description where you
can look up for help get help if you
need it there is help for you and that's
it for me for now squat them out yo I'm
about to burn down this house so you
[__] ready are you ready I'm about to
spill [__] burns like diarrhea I'm
about to nuke the whole city like North
Korea are you ready
that person in the suicide forest